someone needs to say something and why
not me
starting a conversation is just that
it's a start
how much of a responsibility now is it
on Megan and Kate to help modernize the
royal family I think that they're sort
of doing it naturally these two women
from normal upbringing czar
single-handedly redefining what it means
to be royal and were counting down the
nine ways they've already managed to do
that over at the last decade at number
nine the very real PDA Megan Marco and
Prince Harry exhibit whenever possible
[Music]
[Applause]
sure they're still newlyweds only having
tied the knot in a fairytale wedding
less than two years ago but the Sussex
is show their love in a totally
unprecedented way they are a very
tactile couple and public displays of
affection perhaps not what we're used to
seeing with members of the royal family
but with Megan and Harry they've made it
the norm they look happy they look like
a couple very much in love coming in at
number eight the effect megan in kate
have had on the world of fashion we have
seen Megan's wardrobe develop massively
we are seeing her increased sales and
traffic to different sites not only to
both making Kate's clothes sell out
almost immediately after they're
photographed in them Paulette the Megan
Markel effects the Duchess's also use
their influence to promote local and
sustainable designers in Canada we saw
Kate we're urging a canadian-born
designer in America
she wore an unknown British designer to
fly the flags of British fashion so
she's using fashion to send out a
message and to give us an insight really
into her character
what's more both women recycle their
looks
proving that although they're wealthy
they're not above saving a dime we've
seen her recycle a couple of vices of
clothing but this dress was significant
because she stepped out in it
just days after announcing her pregnancy
Plus Megan's even combined her love of
fashion with charity she
passionate about clothes and she loves
fashion I mean this is the woman who
edited the September issue of Vogue and
she recently teamed up with smart work
and designers like metion nunu to
release her first capsule collection and
help underprivileged women
Dress for Success in the past month we
just just the 200th client and and I
think that that just speaks volumes to
the reach and the power that you can
have when you all get together and work
together on such a shared passion
project I think it's fairly incredible
in the work that she does to empower
women and small works is a perfect
example of that
this is the kind of work that I've been
doing for a really long time and to be
able to do it here in my new home of the
UK means quite a bit to me and speaking
of empowering people making in Kate's
work to DS stigmatize mental health has
probably been one of their biggest wins
Kate not only played a pivotal role in
getting Harry and William to open up
about their own struggles mental health
sort of seemed to run between walk in
she also joined forces with the brothers
to form the charity heads together in
May 2016
in May 2009 teen the Fab Four launched
shout a crisis text line for those in
need every mine matters will show you
simple ways to look after your mental
health and of course there's also the
government every mind matters campaign
which the Royals teamed up for in
October it'll get you started with a
free online plan designed to help you
deal with stress boost your mood improve
your sleep and feel more in control
making Kate along with their husbands
are really the first people of their
stature to make it okay for people to
talk about mental health and we can't
talk about giving back without talking
about how the Duchess's support other
women
now that's girl power women need a seat
at the table you can't have a
conversation
empowerment with just women I hope that
men are part of the conversation my
husband certainly is women don't need to
find a voice they have a voice they need
to feel empowered to use it and people
need to be encouraged to listen Megan
might be the more outspoken of the two I
love being a woman a feminist and I love
being girly too so they can all coexist
yeah I love me too girl boss but when it
comes to women's rights kate is all for
it as the future Queen she's just
expected to keep quiet on politically
charged subjects but that hasn't stopped
her from visiting women's prisons or
giving a voice to women suffering from
addiction emotional abuse or other
trauma at number five Meghan in Keith
educational endeavors it was through
scholarships financial aid programs and
work-study where my earnings from a job
on campus went directly towards my
tuition that I was able to attend
University I knew it joyed it so much
that when I had to leave I told my
mother that I was going to come back as
a teacher that's right
both the Duchess of Cambridge and the
Duchess of Sussex are the first royal
women to have a college degree and to
have their own careers before marrying
into the royal family take notes I'm not
gonna repeat myself
I love you Megan with a Hollywood
actress and activist and even ran her
own successful lifestyle blog the TIG I
really do have a organic and deep love
of travel and of food and and also of
writing you know I love writing these
think pieces and off it's about
self-empowerment on this site it's my
baby so I'm very proud Kate worked as an
accessory buyer with British retailer
jigsaw and later as the photographer web
site designer and marketing officer for
her parents event planning company party
pieces this brings us to the way both
women have added diversity to the royal
family first
there with Kate a commoner who
befriended William at the University of
st. Andrews now I see what you're always
talking about followed by Megan who
isn't just a commoner but also an
American and divorced until about 2002
members of the royal family weren't even
allowed to marry someone if they were
divorced and their former spouse was
still alive oh and did we mention that
mm is the first mixed-race person to
marry into the British monarchy
plus she's introduced all kinds of
American traditions like having a baby
shower and giving a speech at her
wedding the first person to get up and
speak was Megan and this was a real
breach of tradition usually the bride
doesn't talk the 38 year old even
refused to do the traditional post
partum photo call on the hospital step
after Archie was born magic it's pretty
amazing
and I have the two best guys in the
world so I'm worried
and that number three the way Megan and
Kate are breaking tradition with their
kids you marry into the royal family but
that doesn't mean you can't have a
regular family with cute children
for starters Kate's daughter Charlotte
literally made history becoming the
first female member in Britain's royal
family to maintain her place in the
Thrones line of succession following the
birth of a male heir in this case it was
her little brother Louie and while
William and Kate have made it a point to
give their kids a relatively regular
childhood complete with dirt bugs and
pizza it seems Harry and Megan are
pushing things even further with not
following naming convention it was a
very deliberate decision by the couple
not to give Archie the HRH title I think
the couple are determined for Archie to
have as normal and life as possible at
number two of the Dutchess of Sussex in
the Duchess of Cambridge's tabloid
takedown at the end of this year when
I've completed my diary of official
engagement I will be reducing the extent
of the public life I've led so far
Princess Diana
sadly fell victim to the press and
making Kate are no exception but they're
not letting it ruin their live Kate
Middleton Prince William's girlfriend
celebrates a birthday today and in the
tradition of Britain's tabloid press
they've given her a not-so-nice nickname
remember when Middleton was dubbed away
tkt before William popped the question
well Kate got the last laugh on that one
she'll be Queen one day and as for
making the British media has been
ruthless not many people have asked if
I'm okay but it's
it's a very real thing to be going
through behind the scenes but she's not
letting that stop her in October she and
Harry announced that they're suing the
Mail on Sunday and rounding out at
number one the way Megan is determined
to live life her own way the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex have done everything
they can to break free from the royal
family including moving to Frogmore and
starting their own royal foundation and
Instagram account which they later used
to announce Archie's name which is a bit
of a break with tradition there's even
talk that the Sussex is might move to
Africa or purchase a second residence in
the States the royal couple is bound and
determined to modernize the royal family
and to do things their own way we're a
fantastic team we know real
you